it looks like kim kardashian couldn't
keep up with the shots at her sister
kylie jenner's 25th birthday bash it was
really tough for me yeah you can say
that it all happened as kylie rang in
the big 2-5 aboard a private yacht with
family and friends she turned it into a
little vlog for tick-tock
birthday party on the boat
[Music]
with birthdays come presents and as
kylie opens up her luxury gifts kim who
doesn't drink alcohol surprises her
fellow party goers when she asks this
does anyone have a shot i can take yes
[Music]
asking you shall receive kimberly why
not
wait
the beauty mogul totally spits the shot
back into the cup it was a nice try kim
you just gotta roll with it kim rolled
with it this time and maybe it'll be the
last time again kim's not exactly the
slamming shots type the biggest
misconception of me is that i'm a wild
crazy party girl i mean i
don't even drink alcohol so i can't stay
up too late in parties but even though
kim tapped out the shots kept coming
kylie also threw one back with lala
anthony
[Music]
my glass was empty
25 drops
for the party
they're joking that they're taking 25
shots for kylie's 25th birthday right i
love it we're sure all the birthday fun
is a nice escape for kim she's coming
off her breakup with pete davidson a
source tells e.t the pair split after
the spark between them faded they had
tons of chemistry and still do but she
kind of wants to be single and date pete
is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met like the best
heart he's really really thoughtful and
humble and just so genuine i would say
the perfect word to describe pete is
genuine our source says all that love is
still there the two just work better as
friends quote there's no drama or
anything weird between them now no drama
just vibes and we hope the tick tocks
from this b-day adventure keep them
coming even if kim can't always hang
happy birthday
wait
[Music]